our next script is called lullabies of
la haula by Karen McDermott separated
from her family during a desperate
border crossing and held in a cage for
migrant children 14 year old valya
Ramirez draw strength from the wisdom of
the poetry of a Spanish revolutionary as
she struggles to survive in the
aftermath of a brawl in the cage
Dahlia spends a hellish night singing
lullabies to the younger girls trying to
drown out the screams of boys being
beaten by guards and then finally a
moment of peace in this scene she meets
a 16 year old Salvadoran boy named Juan
Alberto who will become her first love
exterior recreation field day watching
the smaller boys play soccer
Dahlia hears the sound of dusty
footfalls behind her and a voice see it
out there the warning Dalia turns to see
one Alberto follows the direction of his
gaze I'll pass the fence blue-and-orange
with the face at Lua painting on it the
Aztec god of water
tell your squints into the distance
looks for a colorfully painted rock -
tack prayed to prevent drownings I see
it he gives her a charmingly
don't laugh I smile you're the one who
brings Hector over at night I am Dalia I
know yeah she smiles looks back out at
the distance what's the warning Rock
warning about well this is flush to the
ground so you can't see it unless you're
right upon it
the gringos don't know is there they
don't know how to read the warning how
do you know about it there's a hole in
the fence you tried to escape no no no
there's no place to escape to
I just wanted to see the rock close up
they stand in silence both looking at
the bit of color of their culture in a
sand and barbed wire filled horizon
do you know Miguel Hernandez the poet
one alberto shakes his head he has a
poem about a well it gives me hope she
recites in Spanish una Alba milk area
Piedra tres Piedras Moreau
troz Moreau a Mason wanted stone after
stone one well after another one Alberto
listens his dark eyes drawn into the
story or its teller as she continues je
de trabajar ah Gonzaga
this time Juan Alberto provides the
translation he laughed he worked you say
Dalia smiles una Alban in Korea pero
aquellos rila Brava
sukar sell again he translates
Mason wanted but that man was fashioning
his Jail en sobre fueron precipitous el
e el viento and both he and the wind
were thrown and taste work he considers
he dies and the well he built but you
said I gives you hope the American
president is always building stone after
stone she looks out at the stale desert
but the wind is coming I think
[Applause]